there are two things that set Belfast
apart its dividing walls and the ability
of its people to see beyond them when
they have to behind the barriers some
have self isolated for decades Catholics
and Protestants on different sides now
facing the sium threat coronavirus Jim
is an Irish Republican John comes from a
loyalist background they are serving
together on the CM covered response team
we're both from different sides of the
community and we have a get there and we
would get there that Gilders we want to
stop and I think people are starting to
put Loyalists have halted the marching
season here they won't be gathering to
mark ancient victories on the 12th of
July religions nothing if we're both
caught were both bleed red ever broke
contract covered 19 end up in hospital
religions nothing and that's about you
know you turn this period and being
proactive and using it as a springboard
to take ourselves forward sasha is a
wedding photographer but ceremonies are
prohibited so she's been capturing the
lives of her neighbors instead I've had
people are pajamas around people and
their socks and their slippers they've
had people that are dressed up for the
occasion and just really as they are
today for they look back on these are
her doorstep Diaries she's adopted the
idea of a New York photographer not for
profit but to lighten the mood and
record history the families as well
themselves have all been saying that
it's something that they are really
grateful to have so they'll be able to
show their children because a lot of
children are saying what's going on and
sort of no one that it's different but
it's not for a few years time but
they'll be able to appreciate like the
gravity of what was happening night
it's something that we're probably never
gonna experience ever again so I feel
it's really important that something
like this is documented that we can look
back on and years to come even for our
kids our kids to remember this part of
history and then even for them to show
their kids in death as in life there's a
new normal
Northern Ireland has complex funeral
rites and rituals normally centered on a
gathering called the wake they're the
differences of our communities disappear
and people cry together they had health
stories and laugh and that's part of the
grieving process as well
ian has been an undertaker for 30 years
only once before had he overseen a
funeral with no family or clergy able to
attend given that the work is such a
fundamental aspect of our culture here
do you think Northern Ireland is
struggling with the loss of that more
than perhaps England Scotland and Wales
wilwayco much much more you know the
other thing is that it's it's a complete
community event and we're struggling
with it because we can't actually see
the person so we have no mental closure
on the person's death and that's what
the problem is decades of violence and
thousands of deaths left a legacy of
resilience in Northern Ireland people
here are adept at finding hope amid
adversity that's the spirit of a place
that punches way above its weight this
is game number one on the tee from
Northern Ireland Darren Clarke
the signed of summer at royal Portrush
but the course that hosted the open has
been forced to close Northern Ireland's
world-famous links in Locke died nine
months ago the eyes of the world were on
the causeway coast
the contrast between Saenz at this
seaside resort could not be greater tens
of thousands of spectators made their
way here for the tournament and we're
overlooking the 18th green where she
Inari was crying to champion golfer no
one imagined a day when play would be
halted by a pandemic golf it's bit of an
irrelevance at this time obviously the
the well-being of our members or staff
is at the forefront of our minds but I
think we have to look at the wider world
and you know our NHS staff and so on
I'm the issues that they're dealing with
the biggest names in golf dined on the
finest Northern Irish produce those who
did the catering for them faced a very
different challenge no ballet liske farm
would usually be producing artisan
cheese for the high-end market instead
they're delivering milk and other basic
necessities we couldn't travel with them
due to government restrictions but
shattered by phone while they made their
rhymes Dane is this turning back the
clock whenever one personally I was at a
you know we used to have a milkman we
used to have a bread plan we used to
have a fishmonger and the postman and
those were for people that you know used
to regularly call with you know
good quality food and this is exactly
the service of where we're trying to put
back on the map again from crafting
cheese for the royal family to
delivering milk to neighbors in
isolation that's life in lockdown for
this fifth generation farmer sometimes
it's the simplest things that matter
most
David Blevins Sky News in Northern
Ireland